we're here to find a potential date for
ashley
and joy has narrowed it down to two guys
and we're gonna surprise
ashley with her date that's why she's
wearing a blindfold
no this show has not changed format
we're surprising
ashley all right the remaining two
maxwell
and matthew now have to answer one more
question each and this time that
question's coming from
joy all right maxwell
you are up first joy will you ask
maxwell your question okay so
what is your best and worst quality when
it comes to being in a relationship
good question um i'd say my best quality
um
like sense of humor and ability to
listen to my partner
get along um
worst probably i can
be late to things like i i'm bad at
showing up on time
i've heard of worse qualities um matthew
you're next joy will you ask your
question please
yeah i'll ask the same question what is
your best and worst quality when it
comes to being in a relationship
um so for my best i'd say i'm definitely
like super understanding like loyal like
big into listening like love to just
like hear what the other person has to
say or else like
nothing's gonna really work out if
you're not really it's just a one-way
conversation
and uh you know the worst qualities like
i overthink a lot like i tend to
ignore my own needs and like i have a
difficulty
acknowledging and addressing like
problems when they're coming up and i
just try to like
you know stuff it away but like i
understand this now and you know i'm
self-aware so i'm definitely working on
any of that
well that's hard to admit so good for
being honest about yours i appreciate
that
okay that's good we all have things we
need to improve on that's true
um okay ashley what are your thoughts um
from listening um everyone's everyone
including brody who left just seems like
down to down to earth nice guys
um again hard to gauge obviously i can't
see we haven't really interacted but
from
well you said it wasn't about looks i
know i know
you're right you're right i did all
right
it's the moment of truth joy who are you
going to choose for ashley may i ask
okay um
i think maxwell maxwell
sorry matt um joy
i am just gonna say that if i had to do
the choosing
i would have made the same choice really
i really am
being totally honest and i do think that
you have
uh your granddaughter's uh best interest
i do
yes and ashley are you ready to meet
maxwell
i am all right take that blindfold off
all right here we go
hi hello what's wonderful
are you nice to meet you i'm great i'm a
little nervous if i can be honest
oh it's okay is new to me
oh my gosh well yay i'm so happy that
i don't see anyone else but you look
great
don't worry about them don't worry about
them i have to say as
awkward as this is i'm actually thrilled
with the outcome
i'm thrilled
okay now maxwell um now that you've
actually
said your ideal first date ashley
would you mind telling me what your
ideal first date is
um yeah so a first
date in the city usually a nice
restaurant i love
i'm such a restaurant person especially
in new york i'm always bouncing around
so i love when the guy
picks it and it's something like i've
nev somewhere i've never been to
some place i've never been to um so
starting with that i think it's like my
ideal like
first date cool restaurant um
uh yeah maybe rooftop action
so yeah i think that's what maxwell said
rooftop i think you did we can skip the
museum we'll go right to them we can
totally do a museum
yeah i mean we'll save that for the
second day i think that's a good second
date spot
yeah i i love a museum not that i have
anything to do with this but
um i think this was really fun joy how
are you feeling about it right i'm great
i'm fine with it sounds good okay good
i'm glad
um all right well we would love to make
sure that dinner is taken care of so
we're just gonna
pay for that dinner and add a bottle of
champagne
thanks to visa gift card dinner is on it
oh thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you
thank you joy you got it and um ashley
and maxwell most importantly now that
you guys have gotten through
this it'll give you a great base for
conversation on your heart
hundred percent thank you so much
you